Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain is
unlike any other installment in the
series Kojima Productions latest title
presents a vast open world full of
possibility and if players don't know
the basics straightforward missions can
fall apart quickly here GameSpot
presents a video guide offering 9
survival tips for any would-be
infiltrator first up dropped into the
enormous open world of Afghanistan this
time without the comfort of the series
iconic soliton sonar radars freeze mgs 5
leaves players more exposed than ever no
longer can you Scout enemies by
following dots on a viewfinder
everything now hinges on your own
in-game perception skills which means
the most important advice for all
beginners is to use your binoculars more
than any other item as soon as you
notice even the slightest hint of enemy
activity immediately equip the
binoculars by pressing r1 and locate
your target through the scope it only
takes a few seconds and once you spot an
enemy they will be permanently tagged
the benefits are significant once tagged
enemies will be outlined in red and even
if they walk out of view or stand behind
obstructions a silhouette of their
position will still be viewable from any
angle tagged enemies also appear on your
idroid map giving you a far better
understanding of your surroundings
getting into the habit of equipping
binoculars is a crucial step for
beginners but understanding how to make
the most of them is equally important
the majority of enemies who blow your
cover will be the ones you didn't tag so
it's crucial to scope out areas from a
vantage point where you can see as many
people as possible that means you're
gonna need some heights or CH initely
the plains of Afghanistan provide plenty
of areas for high altitude be at the
crest of a hill the edge of a cliff
overlooking a base or even atop one of
the enemy's own outposts never
underestimate the difference a few
meters can make even clambering onto the
rooftops of an outhouse sized prison
cell could give you just enough of an
angle to spot an enemy behind a wall be
aware of the side ups available in the
missions tab of your idroid device one
of the earliest missions available is to
capture and extract a Russian soldier
who also speaks English
Margot pledged though it's technically
an optional side quest this should be
considered a priority one operation
capturing this target alive will give
big boss and his team a Russian
interpreter without him on your side you
won't be able to interrogate and extract
information from any other Russian
soldiers with a Russian interpreter on
your team it's time to reevaluate the
rules of engagement if you spot a lone
soldier exposed and broken from the pack
tranquilizing or assassinating them is
still a viable option but even better is
capturing them in a chokehold to do that
you sneak up from behind without being
detected and hold r2 when a close range
here you can force your victim to talk
by holding a blade to their throat the
Intel you extract ranges from useful to
invaluable with intimidated guards
pointing out persons of interest or more
exotic weapons hidden away once you have
all the info you can choke enemies out
or if you'd like to indulge in your
sadistic side you can quietly stick a
blade between those
before each main mission begins malagos
solid 5 takes players to a loadout
screen where big boss can be equipped
with primary weapons and hand pistols as
well as other useful items but perhaps
just as important is the time of arrival
option which lets players fly into the
Afghanistan map at either 6 a.m. 6 p.m.
or as soon as possible without a doubt
entering a mission at dusk is the most
useful of these times granted it's not
the best way to appreciate the game
striking landscape but in the shade of
night the chances of being spotted
decrease significantly the Russian
guards line-of-sight is diminished to
the extend the big boss can sometimes
freely sprint across areas he would
usually have trouble sneaking into your
trusty diamond horse is an invaluable
companion summoned by pressing l1 and
selecting the whistle command the horse
allows you to traverse the vast plains
of Afghanistan at speed however more
surprising is how useful your steed can
be but stealth pressing the X button
when on a horseback allows big BOTS to
hang on to the horse from one side in a
way that makes it look unmanned if you
from the opposite side this can be a
particularly easy way to walk straight
past guard outposts in plane sites
without sending off an alert guards will
fix their eyes on D horse as it trots
past but few infiltration methods are as
time efficient as this one
in typical metal gear style triggering
alerts from guard will rapidly escalate
the proceedings into an all-out war
whilst going 90s Action Hero and enemies
does have its cathartic charm constantly
getting into battles will slow your
progress significantly the safest and
easiest way to avoid this is to go off
piste completely avoiding the main roads
on your way to the next objective it's
not the most scintillating option
granted but it's certainly useful if you
need to rest and decompress there are a
few things more disgracefully satisfying
in Metal Gear Solid 5 than a clean
merciless headshot however the
non-lethal approach of capturing enemies
will be far more helpful in the long
term in opening hours of the game big
boss will be given about a dozen fulton
surface-to-air recovery chutes to use in
every mission
these are baffling devices that propel
unconscious enemies to the heavens as
though they will weightless it's
quintessential Kojima logic of course
but also a quick and clean way of
capturing enemies for your mother based
as you begin to accumulate incarcerated
soldiers all of which fortunately appear
to be eager to work on mother base you
can start assigning them various duties
based on their skills open your eye draw
and go to the mother base tab and select
staff management to do this although you
probably didn't sign up to metal gear to
take part in micromanagement it can help
build up significantly the more people
you have on your R&D team for example
the more weapons they can research a
manufacturer for you alternatively more
manpower in your Intel teams will give
you wider and deeper information about
Afghanistan
it is inevitable in every first
run-through of a Metal Gear game that
you will be spotted alert the guards and
trigger a manhunt on you however both
ground zeroes and a phantom pain of a
tiny grace period to dispatch enemy
guards who have spotted you this super
slo-mo reaction time is called reflex
mode and lasts about 3 seconds while the
amateur instinct is to blast away at
enemies during reflex mode panicking
like this tends to not end well
just stay calm line your crosshair on
the enemy's skull and fire just once so
there you have it our survival guide on
Metal Gear Solid 5 or the latest on the
phantom pain make sure you keep it
gangsta
you